hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play scp-432 okay
this is a game that I actually played
before but it's been heavily updated
since I got back to it I played it back
in late January some so it's been a
while anyway tell us how to play moment
collect all five artifacts and exit
flashlights place bar to play it's blur
stick alright anyway stop lollygagging
around and let's get to it before it was
just a very simple experimental thing
we're all you had to do was get to well
before it was just find the monster
basically but now there's probably been
a lot more work put into it so anyway
let's stop admiring the work and get
into it it's been a while since I've
gotten a really good scare so hopefully
this game can provide that's all I can
really hope for now the flashlight does
not go very far by the by what is that
leaves not an artifact
I found an artifact on artifact it's not
an artifact in our teeth act why are
some leaves artifacts I don't know I
don't know stop looking at me like that
I'm focusing on the game here Oh dead
end
as I recall before the monster didn't
have perfect behavior and he sort of
clip through walls which meant that he
was a son of oh that's just a light I
thought that was an eyeball he's a son
of son of us some I don't know what oh
come on I see a light here I thought
that was gonna be something man yeah
yeah see it's gonna be some so anyway if
you've read scp-432 you know what it is
it's some a closet that has a series of
rooms inside in this really interesting
story so or it's a series of hallways
inside it that kind of easy to get lost
in as you can see I remember the guy who
was developing it he spoke with me and
he said that he was working on making it
a money what are that hello hello what
is that who's that
oh my back at the beginning how am i
back in the beginning wait a minute back
at the beginning because this is a
different place what is that whoa what
is that is that the exit alright found
the exit I guess the mouse sensitivity
is also quite high but yeah they were
talking like in the story there was a
series of pipes here and they didn't
know why I remember seeing those pipes
when I came in this game messing with me
I believe it is anyway yeah I must fires
break good okay this is the way I came
cuz I remember seeing that
I just need to turn left at some point
here or go straight and turn left okay
uh or I'll go this way
okay there's another light the light
seemed to be randomly interspersed
throughout the map and I just know what
dad who's a monster obviously I thought
I heard it in front of me so I turned
around and there it was haha okay
I'm not good that's not good okay so
this is definitely a different entrance
from where I found the exit before this
game's gonna be hard if that's what I
have to deal with
that's not cool breath not cool bro yeah
okay all right coming back
oh is that an artifact a giant beer can
definitely I found an artifact artifact
how do you care what the artifacts are I
just want to get up and get out of here
yeah the audio in this game they changed
it from what it was before but I kind of
like the other one - just cuz um it was
just really slow down strings and it was
not a lighter what was that okay that's
just a light cuz like wait a minute wait
a minute if you couldn't tell before the
monsters eyes are red yeah
haha they're red haha I'm gonna die Erna
I'm gonna die so hard I'm only gonna
find one artifact at a time cuz this
whole place is just a labyrinth and I
have no Papa Papa found boots boots were
another artifact somehow boots are
another artifact isla leaves a beer can
I'm a lumberjack I'm trying to find my
old gear so I can go back to
lumberjacking lumberjacking sounds like
something wrong
hey hey Coll of jacket
yay I gotta remember that in this game I
am NOT a monster in this game I hear
that I hear you I hear you breathin I
hear it breathing and then there's
nothing I can do
where was it I guess the breathing was
it kind of being right here on the back
of my deck I heard it it wasn't very
loud announcment that it was there it
was a gradual I'm right behind you
that's good that's good that's bad but
that's good apparently now why do I
choose to play these games oh yeah if
you all like watching me okay alright so
anyway if I go left I don't think this
map is procedurally generated I spit all
over myself I don't think this map is
procedurally generated which means that
it should be in the same place as before
right right unless the spawn locations
are randomly generated which could mean
that I am in for a yeah that's okay
your cans in the same place that's good
okay at least there's gonna be some
consistency I guess cuz this takes hard
already know how I'm gonna survive I'm
okay
gotta find the boots I just want to go
lumberjacking I want to go jack me some
lumber I'm a lumberjack and I'm okay I
sleep all night at a work all day I wear
high heels some house whose benders and
a bra there's my boots not my high heel
boots but just my regular boots
okay so we're making better time than we
were before do I have a run I don't have
a run I can't even run oh crap I knew
that dead end was there I just kind of
forgot about it I don't like this place
I don't like it I want to go home I
don't even know where home is like many
of the other SCP things they send I hear
you out I heard you you're not gonna get
me
all right here Army's getting louder I
mean just getting closer oh oh oh oh no
oh no oh no ow where is he where is he I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know oh oh that why'd
you stop
why'd you stop why'd you stop what's
your top was that oh no that's a dead
end i know that i know that i know
that's a dead end
diffic dad keep hitting the dead ends
why do I keep going with that ants I got
a star huh I'm gonna die i I'm gonna die
the mood I scared it alone inside a room
where I don't want to be artifact okay I
found three but I've made a loop around
the entire place don't kill me don't
kill me bro don't kill me please what is
s what is all that
what is that okay that's new so where am
I now I only do more advice I need to
get to the eggs now I need to get me
hating I don't know where I'm going I
have no point of reference everything
looks the same
oh oh oh that was that my wig I think
that was my wig I found my wig
okay good now that I have my wig I just
need to find my axe I'll be out here
I'll be out here right cliff no idea
where I'm going yeah it'll be pure luck
if I find anything else in this place
pure luck but that's what my life aw
crap ah crap a dead end is not pure luck
if you're bad luck
ah nah yeah yeah oh okay I thought I
found another dead end
this games getting to me I'm starting to
de-stress myself a nah
dirty oh wow okay I REO o kill me bro
go kill me bro don't kill me bro just
let's be 90 calm here I have job Go Go I
why can't my battery powered fossil it'd
be more flashlights powered oh crap I
went down this way before I remember
seeing the bio things about my head oh
no oh no oh no oh no I can hear him but
I seem to be getting away from him a
little better each time and then it
looped again that's good that's good
that's not good but I think I'm away
from him for now I don't even know where
I'm going I don't know where I'm going
I'm just going in sir oh come on I'll
piss clicking randomly hoping to find
something anybody anybody okay
oh come on I've been here I've been in
these dead ends before Oh
okay I'm done I'm gone you guys play it
you're playing you guys play that you do
that you guys do that you guys pick it
up from here so anyway that's it for now
game gets another update up late again
links in the description and always so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the in the dates of more
videos it I've done and as always I
won't see you in the next video
Wow
oh yeah
Oh
yeah
not
ready
Oh
permanent pad tube